welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
in this video we're breaking down an
alternate theory that you might have
seen surrounding the ending of race by
wolves
obviously as we're talking about the
last episode there will be heavy
spoilers here
so if you haven't seen the series yet
then i highly recommend that you turn
off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for videos like this every day and
please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy it
without all the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
breakdown
okay so raised by wolves ends with
mother giving birth
to a snake-like creature that forces her
and father to fly through the core of
the planet
in order to take the monster away from
the humans that's a very top-level
view of the ending and though we don't
know the full ins and outs of how this
happened
when discussing the matter showrunner
aaron gazowski cleared up some of it
in an interview with the new york times
now when discussing how mother was able
to get pregnant with a serpent in the
first place
he stated the following it's a kind of a
weird thing
because it's almost like she's been
digitally impregnated with information
as it were while she was communing with
her creator in a virtual space
basically having sex in the simulation
something else got inside her and
downloaded her drive with
information about how to build a new
being in essence
mother is like a 3d printer her body
starts to work on that digital
information and it decides that it needs
more organic compounds
because she's an android her body could
download that information
and make something out of it her body
was never designed to give birth though
so it has to improvise a bit to get the
thing out of her
the birth is pretty wild it never fails
to disturb me
same here i don't know what the hell
that scene was
however that should clear some things up
but one of the big questions that
remains
over the season is where did mother
actually come from
well we learned throughout that though
she was used as a weapon by the mithraic
the origins of her design are unknown
and they merely built the necromancers
without fully understanding the hows and
whys
the plans to the necromancers were
handed down through their scriptures
and this allowed them to create the
machines it's basically like when you
put
together an ikea sofa but don't fully
understand
the the pieces of said sofa all the way
they are
terrible analogy i know but just just
stick with me this is going somewhere
because of these plans we know that the
necromancers existed for a long long
time
but one of the characters that we see in
the show actually traveled back in time
and this is how the plans for mother
were able to be created in the first
place
if we're right then when the characters
travel through the planet's
core they actually journeyed back to the
past and this is why when they arrive on
the other side of kepler
it looks lush and filled with vegetation
potentially this adam and eve metaphor
the first man woman and a snake creature
could be the basis of our own religion
and who knows
the series might end with the trio
traveling back to earth several
millennia ago
and passing down the story of their life
which would form the basis of
christianity
this journeying away from paradise would
be similar to adam and eve being cast
out of the garden of eden
and thus it would retain a certain plot
aesthetic
the snake could end up being viewed as
the devil or even worse
it could end up becoming soul if this
theory is correct
and we could spend all day talking about
the allusions to religion in the show
but for the meantime i just want to
focus on the clues in the series itself
firstly the final episode of the season
is called the beginning
and this could be taken either way
really but if our theory is correct
then this could actually hint at the
beginning being where things first
started off
on top of this throughout the season
there are several signifiers that
confirm there was life on the planet
before the humans arrived this includes
the giant pentagonal shape that the
mathrace stumble across
and other elements that we see
throughout the series at one point paul
discovers a cave painting
which seems to depict the ending of the
episode and it's accuracy hints at it
being
something from the past rather than a
prophecy it recreates the exact same
events as the ending
and has the flying snake as well as
mother and father in a ship
now the most interesting of the clues
out of the whole series for me
is the neanderthal skull and the helmet
which is revealed to have a necromancer
head inside of it
from the brief flashes that we get of
this helmet in action it does seem like
this was used in some kind of birthing
pod
and who knows if our theory about mother
travelling back in time is true
then this could actually be the future
version of the character
now one of the key things that kinda
hints towards this is that there is a
mention of devolution
happening in the case of the neanderthal
skull i know people argued with me over
this
on the last video but again in science
there's actually no such thing as
devolution
i'm not lying to you a promise every
single species moves forward and adapts
to its environment
or they simply go extinct devolution
can't exist
because of the way that time works and
all of the animals and plants that
populate our planet
are constantly evolving even a slug is
as evolved as you are
because we exist alongside each other
and have evolved from our origins
up until this point mother and father
would likely know this too
and thus the devolution term has
potentially been used to show that this
skull
is literally a less evolved version of a
human
devolution cannot happen through a
naturally existing process
though and thus the only thing i can
think of that could cause it
is time travel itself now what we could
actually be seeing in the show
are the origins of humanity and through
time travel it will be the characters
that we've been following
that end up populating our planet in its
book humans are not from earth
a scientific evaluation of the evidence
ecologist dr ellis states
that there are several indicators which
suggests humans were not born on earth
it hints that our species was in fact
dropped off on the planet by aliens
there are some notable things that seem
to cement this
alice states that humans might suffer
from bad backs because they evolved on a
world with lower gravity
in addition to this we are also home by
the environment
such as sunlight we have a strong
dislike for naturally occurring foods
the highest rates of chronic disease and
also babies heads are so large
that women often have difficulty when
giving birth this can lead to fatalities
in both mothers and infants
and this problem is a purely human one
with no other species on the planet
experiencing it at all we are also far
more developed than any other creature
that exists on earth
and whereas we've grown to learn how to
communicate
play iphone games and order pizzas
animals are unable to
according to ellis another strange thing
is that human body clocks are actually
evolved to expect 25 hour days
which have reportedly been proven by
sleep researchers
so if this is true the show may be
handing out our species being born on
kepler
before we were moved to earth perhaps to
escape
the giant flying snakes yikes
who knows the snakes could have traveled
back to earth but perhaps they arrived
millions of years before the humans
because of the way that time works in
space and thus this thing we see at the
end
actually ended up creating the dinosaurs
now we are getting heavily into the
speculation zone at the moment
let's just summarize our theory while
setting in certain things that may
or may not happen so the end of the
series is actually the beginning
and this is confirmed by the episode's
title what we are actually seeing is the
birth of humanity
and at the end of the entry mother and
father travel back in time
through the planet's core and end up in
their own garden of eden's story
complete with a snake the humans
eventually go searching for them
and potentially using the new ship
that's just arrived on the planet
they travel through the core and also
back in time
here they realize that they are actually
in the past and the mithraic end up
going to war with the atheists once more
to decide who will rule over the planet
this leads to a huge conflict
in which potentially nukes are used and
thus this explains why the cabos
aka the planet's best food source is
highly radiated
the humans realize that the planet will
be inhospitable for a long time
but as they are in the past they know
that at this point in time
earth will be a lush green planet so
they decide to go there
mother and father stay behind with some
of the humans and create the cave
paintings that seem to prophesize the
future
and she ends up dying herself which is
why she finds a skull of a necromancer
that's pretty much it for the moment
another theory isn't airtight
i think there is a lot there that
suggests it could be true
i guess we will see when season 2 rolls
around but yeah that's just a summation
of our thoughts
one week on from the final episode and
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on this theory
and if you agree or not i just want to
give a huge thank you to everyone who
commented on our ending explained video
and helped us spur on a lot of the ideas
in this video there's far too many
people to thank but i really do
appreciate everyone taking the time to
write such thought out and detailed
comments
so give yourself a pat on the back from
me though you better not ever come
within 50 feet of me
otherwise i'll tell you i'm calling the
police now if you want to check out that
video on ironing explained then it's
going to be linked at the end
and don't forget we're giving away three
copies of the marvel phase one box set
all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of october so make sure you
get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also become chapters on our
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video you
been the best
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you